This figure shows the overall processing
of a message to produce a hash value.
The first step is padding so
that the message is a multiple
of 1,024 bits because the message is
going to be processed block by block.
And each block has 1,024 bits.
The padding bits are appended to
the last block of the message.
First we leave the last 128
bits to store the length
of the original message,
that is the length before the padding.
Then for the space between the original
message and the last 128 bits
we add one and a number of zeros
necessary to fill up the space.
And that's how padding works.
After padding, then the message
is processed one block at a time.
Again, each block has 1,024 bits.
The logic of per block processing
is described in the next slide.
The result of processing the current
block is the input to the processing
of the next block.
That is when processing
the second block,
the input includes not only
the second message block but
also the output of the processing
of the first block.
And for the first block,
the input includes the Iv.
The Iv is a 512 bit value,
hard coded in the algorithm.
Again the message is processed
one block at a time.
At each block the input incurs
the output of the processing
of the previous block.
And the result of the processing
of the last block
is the hash of the entire message.
Now let's take a look at
the processing of a message block.
The processing involves 80 rounds.
The input includes not only
the current message block but
also the result of the processing
of the previous block.
And the result of the processing of
the current block will be the input
to the processing of the next block.
The result from the processing of the
previous block is a 512 bit value, and
it is divided into 8 64 bit values.
And they are a, b, c, d, e, f, g, and h.
Again, the processing
involves 80 rounds and
each round the input includes
the result from the previous round,
some constant k, and some words derived
from the current message block.
The constants here provide
randomized values and
the purpose is to eliminate any
logravities with the input data.
The operations at each round
include circular shifts and
primitive pulling functions
based on and, or, not and x, or.
The output of the last round is added
to the input to the first round.
And the result will be used in the
processing of the next message block.